KIRILL TROPIN: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for joining.
My name is Kirill Tropin.
I'm a product manager
in Google Cloud Storage.
CHRIS TALBOTT: And my
name is Chris Talbott.
I am Kirill's counterpart in the
product marketing organization.
KIRILL TROPIN: Today, we'll
be talking about picking
the right Storage class.
And before we begin, I want
to give you a quick overview
of this presentation.
So we'll be talking primarily
about Object Storage.
We'll be talking about
different databases,
and we'll start at a high
level, and go lower and lower
into details of to optimize
performance of your Storage,
and choosing the right
Storage class for your needs.
To start, I want to
show you how Storage
is used across
different industries
and different verticals.
And we can go into
all the details
of each and every vertical,
but the reality is--
Storage you use across the
board for every single vertical.
And if you're not using Storage,
probably you should look
into how you can
start leveraging--
the data leveraging of Storage--
because getting insights
out of your Storage
can really transform
your business.
You can open a new
market, new opportunity,
or help optimize your
cost, or ship new products
for your customers
and your consumers.
And to get into a couple
of examples here--
so Storage is
used, for instance,
for multimedia to
store all the content,
serving the content
to end users,
storing different
transcodes of that content.
For retail, you'll be
looking at different ways
to analyze logs, what
your customers are
buying, creating
different sites,
and helping sell you more.
Then, looking at health
care, for instance,
there's lots of
data for genomics.
Genomes are very
large, and you'll
be storing huge amounts of
data in Google Clould Storage.
I want to tell you a
little bit about journeys
that we see from our
customers, and there
are three typical steps that
we see from our customers
how they transition to cloud.
So first step is called
hybrid infrastructure.
So that's when your
control is still on-prem,
and you're just getting
started with cloud.
Typically what we see is
different bursting scenarios.
You're just bursting your
computer into the cloud,
or you're archiving
data to the cloud.
You're just getting started.
And what we see with Cloud
Storage in those cases,
typically, it's different
archival, different backup
scenarios, and customers
will be leveraging
our core compute, core storage,
and networking infrastructure.
And going a level deeper, the
next stage in the cloud journey
is typically lift and shift.
You're just lifting
your workloads,
moving them to the cloud without
really changing that much.
And some typical examples
is moving your databases,
like SQL databases,
moving your Hadoop.
And then you'll end up
leveraging some of our existing
products, like
Google Cloud Storage,
or storing that Hadoop
data, or storing
different static content.
And you'll be relying
on Google Cloud platform
for your scalability,
and scaling
to much bigger
capacity, and making it
much easier for your workloads.
And then, last stage is
running Cloud native.
That's when you
build your apps--
build your workloads
directly in the cloud.
And typically what
we see there is
people who will be leveraging
our BigQuery, our Machine
Learning, our Spanner,
App Engine, and of course,
leveraging Cloud Storage
for storing and serving--
analyzing the crucial content.
Let's talk a little bit about
the evolution of storage.
So we did not arrive in Object
Storage out of the blue.
So it all started with
Direct Attached Storage,
and Direct Attached Storage
is our typical laptops
and desktops.
That's where you have storage
right next to your computer,
right next to your course.
And everything was fine.
It was growing fine.
People were running
applications on the single box.
But then people realized
that it's not efficient.
You cannot optimize storage,
and compute at the same time,
and fully utilize your CPUs,
and fully utilize your storage.
So over time, people realized
that we should separate storage
from compute, and that allows
you to optimize storage
separately from your compute and
run a full utilization of both
of those.
And that's where SAN came from.
And with SAN, people had to
manage different volumes.
This is a volume
for this workload.
That's a volume
for that workload.
And they got tired,
and they figured out
they can move to a level higher
and move to Network Attached
Storage, where they will
break on files instead
of on volumes, and
then over time,
amount of data just
kept on growing.
Now we have huge
amounts of data,
and the industries realize
that they can no longer rely
on file API for
scalability, so they
shifted to very
simple object storage
API that allows you to scale
for huge amounts of data,
petabytes, even
exabytes, and trillions
of objects in the cloud.
And so today's presentation
will be focused
on Google Cloud Storage.
That's our object
storage in the cloud.
And to introduce
Google Cloud Storage,
it's a highly available,
durable, simple, and secure
object storage Google
Cloud platform.
We call it GCS for short.
And we see a lot of success
across different use cases
with GCS and Google
Cloud platform.
GCS is built on the
same infrastructure
as other internal
services of Google,
and we actually have quite a
few internal customers at Google
using underlying infrastructure
for object storage and serving,
and I'm sure you're using lots
of external Google services
that depend on that
exact infrastructure.
I can summarize use cases with
GCS in three large categories.
So first category is content
storage and delivery.
We see a lot of demand there.
So that's media serving,
image storage, image serving,
music serving.
And some customers
you've heard about
is probably Vimeo
for serving videos,
Spotify for serving music,
and lots of other customers
that store and serve
content out of GCS.
And then moving to
a second category,
that's typically big data
analytics and general compute.
If you have a lot
of data-- petabytes,
hundreds of
petabytes, exabytes--
you've got to store a
huge amount of data.
And for general compute, and
general big data analytics
use cases, you'll probably end
up storing that data in GCS.
And some examples from
different verticals that we see
is health care, different
genomics analytics,
manufacturing, financial
data analytics, e-commerce,
et cetera, et cetera.
And last but not least is
backup and archival use cases.
And I'm showing quite a
few of our partners here,
and we have a long
list of partners,
that can help you
move to the cloud
and back up or archive
your data to the cloud.
So with GCS, with
Google Cloud Storage,
we have four use
cases that target
different needs
or your workloads,
and different needs of
different verticals.
So I'll start left to right.
So left is our
Multi-Regional storage.
That's geo-redundant
storage that's
optimized for
business continuity
because it's geo-redundant
out of the box.
And it's also great for
content serving and delivery
because data is
distributed on our network.
And it's the highest level
of availability across all
of the storage classes.
So typical use cases--
it's serving videos,
serving images, and
different websites,
and different documents as well.
Then, second storage
class is Regional.
Again, it's optimized for
hub storage, hub data,
but it's limited
to a single region.
And what that
allows you to do is
to have your compute and
storage in one single region
that we have lowest
latency and highest
throughput between your
compute and your storage,
and so that's typically
where you see examples
of video transcoding,
different genomics,
and different general
computing analytics.
If you're running
Hadoop workload,
you'll be using Regional storage
along with your VCE cluster.
And then going to the right,
we have colder storage.
So Nearline is our storage for
infrequently accessed data.
Rule of thumb which
we typically give
is if your data is accessed less
than once a month on average,
or you read 100% of your
data per month or less,
the Nearline will be the
cheaper storage class for you.
And moving to an even colder
tier, that's Coldline.
With Coldline, it's
still online storage.
But with Coldline, if you data
access less than once a year
on average, that becomes
your cheapest storage class.
And typical use cases
we see from customers,
they start with their content
in Multi-Regional or Regional
storage.
That content is
very actively used.
After a couple of
months, people realize
that that content is no
longer that frequently used,
and they typically tier
it down to Nearline.
So think of your document--
you create a document,
you will be sharing it
with your colleagues.
And after a couple of
months, the document
won't be that
frequently accessed,
so it's natural to tier
it down to Nearline.
And then after a
year, probably no one
will ever look at
the document again,
so you can tier down all
the way the Coldline.
But before you take full
advantage of your storage
classes, you need to
get your data into GCS.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
And we sort of skipped ahead.
So you know, one of
the things that we
talk about here
at Google are some
of the challenges
associated with how do you
get your data to the cloud.
And try as we might, we
can't move stuff faster
than the speed of light.
So depending on the kind
of data that you have,
the amount of data that you
have for a particular workload,
and then whatever your
network situation may be,
you're facing a
wide gamut of ranges
when it comes to
the amount of time
that it will take to move
that data to the cloud.
In addition to those
sort of challenges
that come from the
infrastructure side
and what your situation
may be, you also
have particular
needs for your role.
So generally when we
talk to customers,
we kind of see folks
falling into three buckets--
IT infrastructure folks,
analysts and marketers,
and then application developers.
So the IT infrastructure
folks, when we talk to them,
they typically have a
need to move their data
from either a current
on-premises data center
or from one cloud to another.
And what ends up being the
characteristics of their data
is that it's large
amounts of data.
It's typically
multiple petabytes.
And they need to bulk upload
that data to the cloud
without affecting their
current network situation
and their current operations.
Now, analysts and
marketers, they're
dealing with data
that's streaming.
They want real time
insights into that data.
They want to learn
about their customers
as quickly as
possible by getting
data about their customers
into analytics tools.
So typically they're
streaming data,
and they need to
automate data transfer
from particular applications
into analytics tools
in the cloud.
And then, finally,
developers, they
need to build applications.
So they want to transfer
their data essentially
with a natural fit into
their development workflow.
So they want to use
the network to transfer
their data into the cloud.
So whatever your
situation may be,
whether you're on the
IT infrastructure side,
or you're an analyst
and marketer,
or you're a developer,
we've got options at Google
for moving that
data into the cloud.
So if you have on-premises
data and a really good network,
you can use our GS util,
our command line interface,
to move your data
using the network.
If you are in another
cloud storage provider,
for example, Amazon S3, you can
use a cloud storage transfer
service to move your data
from one cloud to another.
And if you're on-premises
data, and maybe you
have a bad network situation,
or you have tons of data
that you need to move,
we have offline option,
called Transfer Appliance, and
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a second.
And then, finally, for
those analysts and marketers
out there who are using
a lot of our other tools,
we have a transfer service
that can get your marketing
data directly into BigQuery,
which is our data warehousing
solution, and get you
analyzing that data as
quickly as possible.
Now, across all of
these sort of buckets
of areas of transfer
services, we also
have partners out there that can
help you move your data faster.
Now, I mentioned something
called Transfer Appliance,
and I wanted to highlight
this one particular solution,
because it's a relatively
recent solution
that Google has released.
And this is our rackable,
high-capacity storage server
for moving data without
using the network.
So something that's really
interesting about the solution
is we designed it in
particular for data centers.
So you can order this
appliance from Google.
We ship it to you.
You stick it in
your data center.
You rack it.
It lives there for a while.
We upload your data.
And then you ship
it right back to us,
and your data is available
for all those great services
that Kirill mentioned in GCS.
KIRILL TROPIN: All
right, so let's
go one storage class at
a time, and deep dive,
and talk about
different use cases,
and how to optimize your
storage needs with those storage
classes.
I'll start with
Multi-Regional storage.
Multi-Regional storage is
best for content serving
and delivery.
So our Multi-regional storage
is geo-redundant out of the box.
We have simple
pricing and simple API
to achieve the geo-redundancy,
and it's really
simple for business continuity.
It provides highest
level of availability.
It optimally routes data
within Google network.
Currently, it's
available in three
multi-regional locations--
it's US, Europe, or Asia.
So for instance,
if you select US,
we'll automatically handle
storing data and routing
within our network within US.
If you select Europe,
the same story applies.
We'll automatically store
data in a geo-redundant way
within Europe, and make
sure that we have at least
two replicas, and you
have highest level
of availability for the data.
And common use cases
for the storage class,
as I said before, is streaming
video, streaming music,
or just having a great
level of business continuity
because we take care
of all failovers.
You don't need to worry about
manually failover from primary
to secondary.
We take care of all of that.
And to show how
really simple it is,
I want to show you
a couple of APIs.
So first one is
creating a bucket.
So there's GS util make bucket,
multi-regional location in US,
and then name of my
bucket, and that's it.
As you see, there is no primary,
there is no secondary region.
I'm just specifying that
store my data in the US,
and then we take care
of all your application
on Google site.
And then similarly,
retrieving the data with GETs,
standard HTTP GET.
This is my bucket name,
kirill_us_mr, standard domain
name from GCS, and then name of
my object, which is image.jpg.
And again, there is no primary,
there is no secondary location.
What's cool about it,
if something happens
to one of our regions,
we'll automatically
fail over and route your
request to a secondary location
or tertiary location,
wherever we have your data.
And that means no
downtime in case
of regional failure
on your side,
because you do need
to manually switch
from primary to
secondary, or worry
about implementing
that code, or switching
from primary to secondary.
In a similar way,
the storage class
is optimized for
end user latency.
So we'll be serving data from
the closest available region
or closest available
location from where
the request came from.
We'll also cache
data in the regions
that are nearest
to those end users
that are accessing the data.
And if you mark
the data as public,
that means it's cacheable.
And far edges of
our network, we'll
cache it in more than
100 points of presence
from where the data
was accessed from.
And to talk a little bit
more about the caching,
there is quite a
few things that are
embedded to this Multi-Regional
storage in GCS in general.
So I want to spend
a minute and explain
how does this Multi-Regional
storage compare
to standard solutions
in the market.
Typically what you
see from other cloud
providers or
standard applications
how you store your
data, your consumers
would go directly over public
internet or different providers
to a location, or that region
of the data they stored.
For instance, in this picture,
consumers from a laptop
was going directly to Region B.
With GCS, our approach
is very different.
So you'll have the closest point
of presence in Google network.
And Google network is huge.
Google works really well, and
we leverage the same network
with GCS, and still we have
the closest point of presence.
If your objects are
marked as public,
we'll check in the cache, do
we have this data in the cache?
And then we'll serve it
directly out of the cache
without going all the
way to storage level.
And if we don't have
the data in the cache,
we'll figure out which region is
closest to this location-- it's
Region A or Region B,
and we'll serve data
directly out of that region,
whichever one is closest.
And that really helps
optimize end user latency.
And some of our customers,
for highly cacheable data,
they get insane
performance, they get,
like, millisecond-level
performance of serving data out
of those ops.
In terms of pricing, as I said
before, pricing is very simple.
We charge a simple
$0.026 per gigabyte month
in this Multi-Regional location.
And that's for logical data.
We don't charge you for primary
replica or secondary replica.
We don't charge you
for replication of data
between those two regions.
Everything is included, in
terms of storage, in this price.
And so it's geo-redundant, we
take care of this replication.
For reads and writes, we
have industry standard price
for how much we charge.
And it's really
super low, $0.004
per 10,000 operations
for reads, and $0.005
per 1,000 operations.
Writes, we provide highest
level of availability.
That's 3 and 1/2
nines availability SLA
for this product.
And it operates
even higher-- it's
designed for even higher
availability than these 3
and 1/2 nines.
And again, industry standard
11 nines or annual durability.
And we have the same
11 nines across all
of our products for durability.
Before we deep dive into how
to optimize your performance
with different
storage classes, I
want to show you how we lay
out data in simple terms.
And that really will
help you intuition,
or how to use the storage
classes in which situations.
So starting with multi-regional,
very simplistic view.
It's two replicas, and we
have these two replicas
included for regions.
So as you see in this chart, you
may not have all of your data
in each particular region.
So you will not have
all of your data
in Region A or Region B or
Region C. But for each object,
we'll have two replicas
that are geo-redundant,
and with the geo-redundant--
that replication
in a synchronous way.
And so for instance, if
you're serving this content,
there is no guarantee
that all of it
will be in each
particular region.
But we'll have the
replicas of that content.
Then going to Regional storage,
the situation with Regional
is different.
So for instance, if you selected
Region B for your Regional
storage, all of
your data will be
in that Region B. It will be
redundant across availability
zones within Region
B, and all of it
will be within
that single region.
So that means if you
select your compute cluster
in that same region, you'll have
highest level of performance
between your storage and
compute because all of your data
is in that region.
You don't need to go across
regions on our network.
And then with
Nearline and Coldline,
if you select Multi-Regional
location for Nearline
and Coldline, those
two storage classes
are not geo-redundant,
which is different from our
Multi-Regional storage class.
But with Nearline
and Coldline, it
will be stored in one
of the regions that
are parked with multi-region.
With Nearline and
Coldline, you also
have an option to select
the regional location.
You can say, store all my data
in Region B, and in that case,
it will behave very similarly
to Regional storage class,
where all of the data
is in one region.
Let's talk a little bit
about those best practices.
So as you might
understand, you want
to take full advantage
of our network.
And when you think
about our network,
you don't want to
proxy everything
through a single location.
You want your end
consumers directly
accessing GCS, and
that will allow
you to scale to Gbps 1
terabit per second speeds,
because you'll be taking full
advantage of Google network
instead of trying to go
through a single endpoint,
or single hub.
And that's really the
way for our customers
to scale to huge, huge
volumes of traffic.
Then, similarly,
if you have lots
of requests coming
to those objects,
please parallelize them,
because that will also
allow you to take full
advantage of our network,
with having lots of
parallel requests
coming in at the same time.
And then favor larger requests,
because larger objects
will move faster on
our amazing network.
And parallelize
small operations.
Just keep parallelizing
everything.
Don't have those
sequential operations.
Like, it doesn't
make sense to have
millions of
sequential operations
if you can parallelize them.
All of them will complete faster
if they're going in parallel.
And some rules of thumb--
for a single stream of write,
we have roughly half a Gbps.
For a single stream of read,
we have roughly 1 Gbps.
And if you parallelize,
it scales almost linearly,
with having multiple streams
accessing GCS in parallel.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah, so
Multi-Regional storage, it's
the storage class a
lot of our customers
use for serving our content
to users throughout the globe.
So we've been talking a lot, and
we've been talking very fast.
And we want to switch
it up a little bit
and show everyone a very
simple demo of the few steps
that it takes to upload
your content into GCS.
And then we're going to show one
of the unique differentiators,
the built-in edge-cache
that Kirill mentioned.
And we're also going
to switch up roles.
So we've had the product
guy pitching the whole time,
and we're going to have
the marketer actually
demo the product.
So I'm going to switch
over to the console.
And once I get there,
I'm going to reconnect
because we've been, as I said,
talking for a little while.
So for those of you
who are unfamiliar,
what you're looking at is the
Google Cloud Platform console.
This is how all of our
users and customers
interact with all
of the services
that Google Cloud provides.
So you can see all of
these services over here
on the left-hand navigation.
We're going to store some stuff.
So I need to use some
storage, very obviously.
So I'm going to go into
the storage browser.
And for the purposes
of this demo,
we're just going
to create a bucket,
and we're going to
upload an image.
So as Kirill
mentioned, the way that
object storage works is
you organize your data
into these buckets into
which you put your data.
So I'm going to create
a new bucket here.
And I'm just going to name it--
let's name it the cloud
on air demo bucket.
We'll select Multi-Regional
because we were just
talking about Multi-Regional.
And we'll have that
data live in the US,
and we'll create that bucket.
So now I have my
bucket, and I need
to find some data put into it.
So I'm going to
upload some files.
And I have a list
of various images
that I have used for demos.
KIRILL TROPIN: Oh, they're good.
CHRIS TALBOTT: You
saw our Lego chicken.
So why not use the
image from the slide?
And we will upload
this Lego chicken.
And there you go.
Here is our Lego chicken
image in our Multi-Regional US
bucket.
It's as simple as that--
a few steps to get
your data into GCS.
And once your data is there,
you can serve it to content--
or you can serve it to your
users throughout the globe,
or expose it to any
other services that
are available from
Google Cloud platform.
Now, I mentioned
I wanted to show
one of the unique
differentiators that
comes from GCS, that global
built-in edge-caching
that we do.
So it's really hard for me to
simulate a user at this point
in time requesting data
from London, for instance,
from here.
So what I can do is I could
show you us requesting data
from a bucket that's perhaps
a Multi-Regional bucket
in the EU.
So I'll go back to
my storage browser.
And you can see I have various
buckets in various locations
throughout the globe.
I will go to this
Chris's EU bucket.
In it, I have our
Lego chicken image.
And I'm going to
run a simple script.
And essentially what
I'm going to ask it
is to tell me how long it
takes to request this image
from that bucket in the EU.
So let's run this.
And you can see down here,
this 799 milliseconds,
which is pretty good, right.
It's going a long way to
request this information.
KIRILL TROPIN: From the
other side of the planet.
CHRIS TALBOTT: From the other
side of the planet, yes.
But we can do better, right.
So I mentioned,
unique to Google,
we have that global
built-in edge-cache.
So I need to enable
that edge-caching.
So I'm going share this
Lego chicken image publicly.
I'm just going to make
sure that the cache
control is cleared out here.
And now that I've
done that, I've
essentially enabled
that edge-caching.
And we're going to
run our script again,
getting a little bit
better, 526 milliseconds.
And there you go, down
to 31 milliseconds.
So a massive, massive difference
in how fast a user would really
get that content, because
Google is essentially
trying to push it as close
as possible to me requesting
that information from you.
So for you, as customers of
GCS, whether you're in Tokyo,
or you have users in Tokyo,
or London, or Mumbai,
we're basically going to try
to give those users requesting
your content the best experience
possible for content serving.
KIRILL TROPIN: Yeah,
that's phenomenal.
And it was a 1 megabyte
object or something.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah, it
was a pretty big object.
The Lego chicken
was a large image.
KIRILL TROPIN: Large chicken.
All right, so let's switch
back to our storage classes.
And we'll talk about
Regional storage class now.
So Regional storage
is the storage
that's best for data
analytics, and it's really
best for data analytics, because
you can select a region where
to store your data, and
you can run your compute,
and run different Cloud Platform
tools within the same region.
It's redundant within a region.
It's redundant across
multiple availability zones
to achieve that high
level of availability.
And it's integrated with all
the standard Cloud Platform
tools or products, like
Data Floor, ML, BigQuery,
Cloud Genomics, and
obviously, Compute Engine.
But this is really
the storage class
to use with all those tools.
It's ideal for running general
compute within a single region.
Different data analytics
use cases with Hadoop,
with Cloud DataProc,
data flow, also
for serving that content
within one constrained
geographic location.
And you can also use
the storage class
for region shielding with
content delivery networks
if you want to have
predictability and latency
where your data is
stored, and where
you're exiting our network with
CDN shielding, for instance.
Let me show you an example
of using this storage
class with Hadoop.
So we talked about
that lift and shift use
case for our customers in
their journey to cloud.
And for customers that already
have Hadoop clusters on-prem,
and they want to lift and
shift them to the cloud
and run that workload
in the cloud,
we have a perfect
product for that.
It's called Cloud DataProc.
It's essentially a
managed Spark and Hadoop
service on Cloud Storage.
And what's cool
about DataProc is
that it has Cloud
Storage connector,
and that connector
is HDFS-compliant.
So that means to migrate to
your storage GCS with Hadoop,
all you need to
do is just change
your pointer to
where data is stored.
Instead of having HCFS pointer,
just having a GS pointer.
And that's it.
You don't need to do any
other change to your storage.
You just change
where data is stored,
and essentially upload it
to GCS, change from HCFS
the to GS, and you're done.
Everything else will
keep on working.
And what's great about
using Google Cloud
Storage versus
using Hadoop on-prem
is that you can shut
down your cluster,
and your data will
still be there in GCS.
You can spin off another
cluster and access the data.
So the data is accessible when
your cluster is turned on,
and that allows you
to save a lot of money
on that compute capacity.
You can scale down, scale
up your computer cluster
independently from storage.
And you can learn more about
DataProc and that Cloud Storage
connector on
Cloud.google.com/DataProc.
In terms of pricing,
pricing structure
is very similar
to multi-regional.
Again, it's simple.
In case of regional, it's
$0.02 per gigabyte month
versus $0.026 per
gigabyte month.
And pricing is slightly
different around the world,
but this is our typical
price in US, Europe,
and the major locations in Asia.
Read operations,
write operations
are the same as with
Multi-Regional storage.
Our availability
SLA is three nines,
and this product is designed
for even higher availability.
Again, all the standard
stuff-- the same durability,
the same instant
access, the same API.
So as you saw, it was
very simple to create
Multi-Regional bucket.
API is exactly the same
for Regional storage.
You just specify
that's it's Regional
storage and not Multi-Regional.
In terms of best practices for
using Regional and optimizing
that performance,
when you are running
those analytics workloads,
when you're accessing storage
from Compute Engine, you
should be co-locating your data
in compute.
You should be really selecting
the same region for storing
your data and where you
are on your compute jobs,
because it decreases
your latency,
makes sure you have
the highest throughput.
It also optimizes
your predictability,
because you have predictable
tail latency since your data is
collocated with your compute.
And all the standard stuff--
parallelize your operations,
because you can still take
full advantage of the network
in a single region.
Let's talk about Cool Data.
So for Cool Data, we
have two storage classes,
that's Nearline and Coldline.
I'll start with Nearline.
So Nearline is our
storage class that's
best for infrequently
accessed data.
It has the same online latency,
the same API as other storage
classes.
Common use case is
serving long-tail content.
So remember, I said
it has online latency.
So you can still use
this storage class
for serving your content.
But if that content is
not that actively used,
just put it in Nearline
and serve it directly out
of Nearline.
In terms of storage price,
we charge significantly less
We charge only $0.01
per gigabyte month,
but we charge $0.01
per gigabyte read.
And those two numbers work
out to that rule of thumb,
that if your data is accessed
less than once a month
on average, Nearline is
really the cheapest storage
class for you.
A couple other differences
versus Nearline
and Regional-- so minimal
storage duration in Nearline
is 30 days.
We did not have that concept
for our Hot Storage class.
With Nearline, we have it simply
because we charge so little
for that storage.
And this storage
class is designed
for longer-lived content,
versus Regional, where you
can have temporary stored data.
And then Slightly Lower
Availability, SLA, again, we
optimized this product
for that low price--
lower price-- and
infrequent access.
So our availability
SLA is two nines,
but it's designed to run at
three nines of availability.
And then moving to Coldline.
So Coldline, you'll see very,
very similar to Nearline.
So with Coldline, we
still have online latency.
You can still actually
use the storage class
for serving your content.
It's the same consistent
API as any other--
CHRIS TALBOTT: Wait
one second, though.
So it's archived storage
that has millisecond latency?
KIRILL TROPIN: Yeah.
It's archived storage
with online latency.
As I say, it's archived storage
that you can actually use.
Because you can archive data,
and whenever you need it,
you can still access it,
use it any time you need.
You don't need to wait for
that retrieval from tape
or any other semi-offline
or offline storage
that you're using.
And we have some customers
that actually use
Coldline for serving content.
Customers that have just huge
amount of content, that really
long-tail content, they put
some parts of the content
in Coldline, and they
still serve it out
just because it's not
accessed frequently.
And in terms of
pricing, it's lower
than Nearline for storage.
It's $0.007 cents
per gigabyte month.
And we charge more
for data access,
and those two numbers work
out to that rule of thumb.
If your data is accessed less
than once a year on average,
then Coldline is the
cheapest storage class.
Just to show you how consistent
that API and that performance
is--
so with API it will
look exactly the same
I was showing with the
Multi-Regional storage.
So my bucket is called coldline.
I've claimed that name
for my storage class.
Again, same domain name and
image.jpg, and standard GET/PUT
interface for getting
the data in and out.
For performance, I'm
showing GS util perf diag,
so it's similar to the tool
that Chris was showing,
but with perf diag is our
perf diagnostic as part
of GS util, which is
our storage utility.
And here I was downloading
1 megabyte objects
out of Coldline.
I was not as far as London
versus US in that example,
but in that case, when I was
testing it, I was in London,
and data was in Belgium.
So there was a bit
of extra help there.
And you can see in this example,
its consistent performance
is between 147
milliseconds up to 200
millisecond for uploading
that 1 megabyte object out
of Coldline.
That's crazy.
That's our archived storage.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
if we had wanted to,
I could have served that Lego
chicken image out of Coldline.
If someone was requesting
that image, for instance,
and it was giving them
the same experience
had we had it in
another storage class.
KIRILL TROPIN: That's right.
It's still online storage.
It still relies on the
same Google network,
so it would be just as fast.
Let's talk about using
storage classes together.
I want to remind you again,
all of the storage classes
that we have, because we have
quite a few of them, four.
And so Multi-Regional is our
storage for content serving
and delivery.
It's geo-redundant.
It's available in three
multi-regional locations
worldwide: US, Europe, and Asia.
And we charged the $0.026
per gigabyte month,
a simple price per
logical gigabyte
month if you are storing.
Then going to the
right, we have Regional,
which is storage of PMIs for
access within a single region,
be we charge $0.02 per
gigabyte month of storage.
So it's slightly cheaper.
And then Nearline and
Coldline is infrequently
accessed storage
and cold storage.
And for those storage classes
we charge much less for storage,
but we charge more for access.
And a typical rule of thumb--
for Nearline, it's data that is
accessed once a month or less;
and Coldline, accessed
once a year or less.
And what's cool about
all these storage classes
is that they have the same API.
And having that API allowed us
to have object level storage
class and data lifecycle across
all of those storage classes,
and you can really transition
between storage classes
very smoothly, and
without changing URL,
without changing your API,
how you interact with data.
You can simply change storage
class, and all of your tools
will keep working.
So to simplify that
lifecycle for you,
we created Data Lifecycle
across storage classes.
It's a feature that
launched about a year ago,
and we allow you to
automatically set
policies and transition
data from hot storage
to cold storage based
on the age of the data.
So a typical example that
we see is for documents,
as I was telling earlier.
Within the first 30
days, that document
is accessed very frequently,
people interacting, editing
the document, and
so you will probably
be storing it in
Multi-Regional storage class.
After 30 days, you
can set a policy
to move it down or tier it
down to Nearline, and then
after another 90
days, or 180 days, you
can, say, tier down
to Coldline, and GCS
will take care of
that tiering down,
and you don't need
to change anything.
Your API's the same, your
bucket name is the same,
your object name was the same.
All of your code
would keep on working.
Even if that document ends
up in our coldest tier,
all the stuff will keep on
working with the same API.
All right, so some closing
notes before we switch to Q&A.
So I want to remind, we
have four storage classes.
They're tuned for different
use cases for object storage.
We have the same API,
the same online latency
across all of them.
And that really simplifies
your management of your data
and how you access the data.
All of these storage classes
rely on Google network.
And our peering, we
have open peering policy
with Google Cloud Platform.
We have lifecycle across
all of the storage classes.
You can learn more about us if
you just Google "Google Cloud
Storage," or just go to
Cloud.google.com/storage.
We have free tier and
free trial with GCS,
so please go ahead
and try it out.
Upload your Lego chickens
and see how fast they are.
Yeah.
That's all I have.
So we're going to
take a minute break,
and then we'll switch to
Q&A, and we'll be back.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
Thank you so much.
KIRILL TROPIN: Thank you.
All right.
Thank you for listening to us.
We have quite a few
questions coming online.
And so we'll try to answer
as many of them as we can.
So we'll start
with the first one,
when will GCS be
available in my country?
And so what's interesting
about this question
is the difference between when
it's going to be available
versus when it can
store data in GCS.
So GCS is really
available pretty
much in all the countries in the
world where you have internet
with just a few exceptions
where we're not allowed
to have Google services.
And as we talked
about, our network,
we have 100 points of
presence around the world.
And wherever you
store your data,
we'll be delivering
it to our network
to the closest
point of presence,
and then within public
internet within that country,
even if we don't have that
point of presence with Google.
So really, you can store
data anywhere in GCS
in those locations
that are available
and access the data
around the world.
So it's really
available worldwide.
So second question, can I
use GCS as a Content Delivery
Network or CDN?
Yes, you can use it.
Because like we talked
about that edge-caching,
it sounds quite familiar
or quite similar to CDN
technology.
But surely, if you want to
optimize your performance,
if you want to
optimize your cost,
you can use GCS as origin
or storage for the content,
and then use our
Google Cloud CDN
and some of our CDN partners.
If you're already using CDN,
it's pretty easy for you
to transition, move that
origin storage into GCS
while keeping your CDN provider
that you're using today.
And even if you
don't need that CDN,
even if you don't have that much
public or cacheable content,
GCS will serve as a basic
CDN with caching that content
on the edge.
All right, third
question, can I control
where my data is stored?
Absolutely.
So we have about 15
regions worldwide.
As we talked about,
that regional storage,
or using Nearline and Coldline
in regional locations.
You can select that region
and store your data in one
of those specific locations.
And we're constantly
shipping new regions.
So just last week we
launched two new regions.
We launched the Netherlands
region and Montreal region.
And we're constantly adding
more and more regions
to Google Cloud
Platform and GCS.
And if you select
the region, we'll
keep data in that
region, and that way
you can have highest performance
between compute and storage.
And on top of that, we also have
three multi-regional locations
where we take care of the
geo-redundancy and replicating
data across multiple regions
within that multi-regional
location.
All right, fourth question--
this is a question for you.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
how long does it
take to transfer and load
data using appliances?
It's faster than sending
data over the wire.
So I'll take the latter
half of that question first.
So you saw that very
multicolored graph
that I showed.
You could find it
on Cloud.google.com
/TransferAppliance as well.
Basically, it depends.
It depends on your network
situation and how much data
you have.
What we've found is that
typically organizations
have a couple-hundred megabit
type network connection,
and then they have
multiple petabytes of data.
So if you're in that
sort of situation,
then Transfer Appliance
can make a lot of sense.
Now, dependent on whether or not
you have less data, or perhaps
a faster connection,
it might make sense
to upload data over
the wire instead.
So typically, we have two
options for Transfer Appliance.
We have a 100 terabyte option,
and we have a 480 terabyte
option.
Let's take the large
one as an example.
It could store upwards
of a petabyte of data.
It takes a while to load
that onto Appliance.
It takes a while to
ship it, also, to you,
and ship it back to us.
So it takes somewhere between
a month and two months.
So you got to check out what
your network situation is,
and it might make sense to use
the Appliance, it might not.
KIRILL TROPIN: All right.
So next question,
is GCP Storage--
GCS-- faster than
storage on other clouds?
So thinking on
this question, you
could look back to
our architecture
and all the advances that Google
has made with our network.
So GCS typically would be faster
than other cloud providers
for larger objects, or when
you're serving the content
outside of our network.
Because in GCS, we're
carrying data on our network
for as long as possible.
It's built in out of the box.
You don't need to tune anything.
You don't need to
draw any acceleration.
You just start using GCS,
we will be carrying data
on our network.
So typically, you'll see GCS be
faster than options out there.
For larger objects, or for
when you're serving data
outside of our
network, and similarly
with edge-caching--
because by default
we have that caching in our
regions around the world.
If you make your
objects public, we'll
take them farther out
from our data centers
in point of presence
around the world.
In those use cases,
we'll also typically
be faster than cloud
providers, because we're
serving data from
the edge, and you
didn't have to turn on
any CDNs, or integrate,
or doing any other extra work.
It just works out of the box
that fast with caching data
on the edge.
And then, last
question, can you speak
to ratio of HDD versus SSD
for different services--
also, different workloads?
Yeah, so I don't
think I can directly
answer about our ratio.
I should.
But if you look at our pricing,
you can see the pricing is
pretty much HDD-based,
because it's so cheap--
$0.007 and $0.026
per gigabyte month.
So you can assume
that most of the data
that you stored on HDD to
achieve that low price.
But as we optimize
end user performance,
you will figure that our
metadata is probably stored
in memory to achieve
highest level
performance for those
small object operations.
And then, for
caching as well, you
can think of different
layers of cache,
that some things
could be cached.
So HDD, SSD, and even memory
to achieve that highest
level of performance
for Hot Data
and frequently accessed data.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
KIRILL TROPIN: All right.
Did you want to add
anything to this?
CHRIS TALBOTT: No, I think--
thank you, again.
KIRILL TROPIN: Yeah.
CHRIS TALBOTT: It's
time to say goodbye
from Kirkland, Washington.
And we're throwing it
back to Mountain View.
KIRILL TROPIN: Thanks so much.